Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Yeah.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast is
ah,
oh,
just checking in on you.
Just checking in,
seeing how your week's go in.
Huh?
Making sure the Celtics feds,
I fucking,
you just got you asses whipped by the Milwaukee Bucks.
Boston slam is over.
Um,
and there's a lot of people that are happy about that.
A lot of sports fans are happy about that.
And I'll ask you this,
what does that say about you as a person?
That that's where you get your joy in the failures of others.
You know,
Boston could have used a sports pick me up.
We only won the world series in the Superbowl
ball this past year.
Um,
I'm just fucking with the,
I do the same thing.
Like,
I'm actually really upset that,
um,
well I guess it doesn't matter because the Lakers aren't in it,
but I want Kevin Durant to be totally healthy and if the Celtics aren't going to
win it just anybody but the Lakers and uh,
but I think that my hatred of the Lakers is justified considering for whatever
reason they get to count a non NBA title as an NBA title.
Um,
and I give it up to the Lakers.
They are the most successful team in my lifetime,
sorry,
MP and shit because my laptop's full here,
empty my trash.
Um,
they are,
they're the most successful team,
the fucking amazing.
And they were able to transition from the old school way right into the free
agency,
way better than the Celtics have.
So I'll give him up on that.
My only thing with them is that take that fucking banner down,
you know,
quit hitting off the ladies tees when all you championships in the NBA.
I think that that's fair.
Um,
but having said that,
I didn't see a second of the Milwaukee Bucks series,
but I definitely,
um,
I dunno though,
I definitely kind of saw,
I didn't see us winning it this year.
I was a little excited when we,
when we swept the pacers,
but,
um,
we just couldn't get into a groove this year.
It just couldn't,
I don't know what the fuck happened.
And I,
it's almost like,
okay.
I Dunno.
It was like,
it was like when,
you know,
when in music,
when they put together a,
a super band,
as they call it,
it's like we'll get the bass player from this huge band and we'll get the drama
from this band and Bob by and all that type of shit.
And you think that this thing's gonna sometimes it just doesn't work.
And I think if you're a good Celtic fan,
get off the fucking internet and stuff,
fucking point and fingers that you clean up your own fucking life.
All right?
Until you put your hatred of the Lakers to bed like me.
No,
you've,
you,
you're not going to be doing this Celtics any by going on there and pointing the
fingers and,
and pointing your finger at people and saying a bunch of negative shit.
MMM.
You know,
leave that to the,
to the analysts or whatever.
They're going to say enough.
But you don't need the fan,
the flames.
Because what I'm worried right now is what's going to happen is everybody's
going to trash Kyrie Irving,
blame him and then he's going to go sign with somebody else and he's going to
have this fire in his belly and it's got to come back to haunt us.
So just,
you know,
whatever.
Sometimes you ever see somebody Redo a car and they just put too much shit on
it.
You know,
too many bells and whistles.
The rims don't,
you know,
should've picked a different ram.
My,
you didn't need this.
He didn't.
It's kind of let,
that was just a little bit too much,
uh,
too much mustard on a hotdog and I don't,
I just don't think there was room enough for the amount of creativity on that
team.
That just wasn't enough touches for everybody.
And people started getting,
I don't know,
something happened.
I don't know what,
they just couldn't get into the flow.
But I do know that we have the best fucking young coach in the NBA and we also
have arguably one of the best gms and Danny Ainge.
So I believe what we were going to be able to fix this thing.
But,
uh,
thank you to the Celtics for a and not,
you know,
we came up short,
but it was still a great year and congratulations to your Milwaukee Bucks and a,
I'd be lying to you as an NBA fan to not say that it isn't a exciting to see
that team after all these years.
I mean that,
I can't remember the last time they had a nice one.
I imagine something happened between Sidney Moncrief and,
uh,
Yanis
I tutored mostly to,
to Poole,
whatever's for La,
I can't say and take to tempo,
um,
sense him.
But,
um,
that is an exciting team to watch.
Uh,
whatever.
It's just,
it's good.
It's good with teams,
you know,
it's not good when just fucking New York,
Boston and la are fucking doing something.
And every,
every goddamn year.
It's just not good.
It's not good for the fucking leak.
So I root for everybody else and I am almost to the point now,
mmm.
Where I'm letting go of my anger of like,
like I just don't,
I don't,
I'm too old now.
I,
I don't give a fuck.
All right.
I'm not going to sit here and waste time and root against the fucking Lakers
even though it was just trashing them,
the Canadians and the Yankees,
like I don't give a fuck anymore.
MMM.
Because no matter how much I hate them,
it's not going to change the result when they play the game.
So what the fuck am I doing?
All right.
God bless all of them.
I wrote for the Boston ones that if you beat us,
congratulations.
How about that?
Was that for enlightened?
And here's a big question,
Bill,
can you sustain it?
It's like I'm an emotional diet right now,
which I need to go on a real fucking died after the shit.
I had one fucking snickers bar in an airport cause they were boarding and I
didn't have time.
And I remember that advertisement where they tried to act like it was actually a
decent replacement for a meal.
Remember when snickers had the balls to do that?
It's packed with peanuts.
Yes.
Surrounded by fucking the food version of heroin sugar.
And I got back on the sugar man.
Okay.
I tied off,
I snorted the first one and then I shot there.
I ate more goddamn candy and dessert on the last four days of this fucking,
this trip.
And uh,
I came home looking like I was fucking getting ready to play Santa Claus on
fucking the next Christmas holiday.
So I,
uh,
I got back on it yesterday.
It's just,
it's just hard to eat well when you're on the road,
but,
um,
people keep the vegetarian meals coming in,
man.
Um,
I'm gonna,
I'm going to do like a hybrid.
My version,
I'm sort of like,
I like the way a rich kid goes to the army.
You know what I mean?
I'm going to be a vegetarian the way George W.
Bush served his country.
I'm going to be in the vegetarian reserves and you know,
not show up for a few days.
Um,
now why pick on him?
I Dunno because we're fucking bankrupt after that fucking
Dash Hirsch our intelligent edge.
Fucking damn good.
I would,
where is that guy?
Can he come out and say he's site now that we're 20 trillion in debt.
Ace.
Sorry about bankrupting your fucking entire futures.
I Dunno.
Partner kind of was talking to me about some shit like that.
I was kind of putting the last tube,
this one in the law and the one before us in perspective with what they fucking
inherited.
It's a fucking shit show.
It's like a water main break broken.
They get you walked in there with a fucking wrench in a pair of rubber boots and
you're supposed to try and fix it.
I don't,
I don't know what I don't know,
but that's too fucking dark.
Okay.
And I'm taking it on the upswing here because I'll tell you this,
I,
at this point
I tend to almost,
I think I've been to 29 different countries,
28 really?
I went to the holy city to have the holy sea,
which is considered its own fucking country.
MMM.
And uh,
the overwhelming thing that I have found is people are nice people.
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
They're just decent walk around that just fucking Nice.
And all of this fucking shit that's going on is the concept of top cause they
want to control everything.
And I really got to tell you,
dude,
just don't fucking watch the news.
I literally went to fucking Israel not watching the news.
Had no idea
that Hamas had shot like fucking six,
700 fucking rockets.
I don't know if it's into Jerusalem and what I had no idea.
Just landed there.
I mean people immediately gave me that information but know people fucking Nice.
The fucking Nice.
And when I got outside my hotel,
I saw some Palestinian people and they were peacefully protesting
and it's just,
people are fucking did.
They're just nice.
They're nice.
Although this fucking,
these are evil doers and these fucking people and all these fucking people
bubble butts like,
no,
no.
What it is,
is this constant like you on the other side of the fucking fence.
Um,
smartest thing I ever did was I stopped watching the news.
Yeah,
I really did.
If you want,
you know,
and I swear to God,
if I wasn't in this fucking business,
I'd get off social media.
If you've got off thing,
imagine if you did this.
If he got off social media,
you stop watching the news.
All right?
And then you fucking,
I dunno,
start reading.
You know what's,
you know,
I watched a really cool documentary,
watch this one.
There's this documentary this kid made who is trying to do a documentary with
Bill Murray.
Bill Murray never got to him.
And then he kinda realized other things or whatever,
but we was kind of investigating all of these stories about Bill Murray walking
down the street and then just jumping in a kickball game with random people
taking pictures and disappeared.
Just kind of watch that thing,
the way that guy,
or at least the way they're presenting,
the way the dude lives this life.
It's pretty,
uh,
I dunno,
maybe I was just stuck on an airplane.
But it kind of affected me when I was watching it.
I actually watched a bunch of great movies.
Yes.
Um,
on the 12 hour flight before the four hour delay,
a connecting flight never connect when you're traveling units or an
international,
as you basically considering it's playoff times,
it's get to the exit owes you basically just increased your chances of a delayed
flight by 100%.
As you doubled the amount of planes that you were taking.
A goddamn it had happened.
Um,
I do want to give a shout out to United Airlines for making it happen.
I thought,
you know,
these guys were up against it with the,
by the time the delay was over everybody,
the stewardesses,
flight attendants,
everybody was up against it and they still went anyways.
You're supposed to get in at like,
um,
10,
15,
la.
Tell Him we finally get in at like 3:00 AM and I basically spent 24 hours
on planes and in an airport.
And uh,
it's just one of those things where it's so far a 12 hour flight is so fucking
long.
You don't even give a shit.
I just sit there as this thing.
All right.
I stayed up for the entire thing too,
and I,
the first thing I watch was this Bill Murray documentary.
Then I watched,
um,
let me make sure I get the names of these movies,
right.
I watched that Jonah Hill movie.
Um,
okay.
Is it mid nineties?
Said what?
It's called bid nineties.
We'll that full movie pay for that thing that she fuck.
Mid Nineties.
Yeah.
Um,
Jody Hill movie,
fucking love that movie.
Great movie.
Incredible performances.
I love the writing and all of that.
And um,
okay.
I was like,
man,
this must get great reviews or whatever.
And I looked it up and so much of the shit was about the language,
the harsh language that was used in all of that shit.
I just don't know.
I don't understand.
When they decided to treat every movie goer out there like they were fucking
child,
you know what I mean?
I want,
remember watching roots when I was a kid.
They didn't have this big fucking thing.
Now there's going to be a lot of a harsh things that you're going to see here.
You don't have roots came out now,
I think they would literally be like,
you know,
is,
is that,
is that the right thing to put out now?
Is this going to start slavery again?
It's just like,
this is the way people talked that the title of the movie is literally called
mid nineties.
Yeah.
Is that 1890s?
I don't understand.
Just watch the movie.
It was fucking like,
I was really blown away by,
um,
yeah,
the performance is too.
And I also love the ending,
which is the hardest thing to land,
um,
is the third act without doing some sort of thing that people can see.
They can see the end coming or something like that.
It was just a fucking phenomenal movie.
So congratulations to Jonah Hill and everybody else that was in it,
the acting the actress in it would just,
they would just there.
I was so fucking great man.
I'd really love that movie.
All right.
And then next up,
what I saw,
I watched a on the waterfront and finally fucking paid attention because I had
to credible movie.
I know that's like one of the best ones of all time,
but I actually sat and watched it.
Loved that one.
Then I watched Dag and to make sure I get this one right too.
The Laurel and hardy movie.
MMM.
Another great one.
Okay.
I was just standing Ali.
MMM.
I watched that movie and just once again,
absolutely fantastic fucking movie.
I made sure I picked good ones.
You know what I mean?
As if I'm going to sit here,
I'm going to make sure I,
I watched,
uh,
you know,
I remember Mark Marin was raving about that movie,
so I'm going to,
I was like,
I'm gonna Watch this,
but uh,
Steve Coogan and John C.
Reilly,
Shirley Henderson and uh,
yeah,
Nina Arianda.
They will like the main,
they play basically a Laurel and hardy and then their significant others and uh,
Nina Arianda,
her character was fucking hilarious.
Definitely check that one out then.
Was that,
that's one,
two,
three set three or four fourth.
That's four with the Bill Murray thing.
And then I watched,
um,
okay.
I start,
I was like,
all right man,
like these are really great movies,
but you really have to pay attention.
Let me watch something a little sillier.
And they had saint elmos fire was on there and I got through maybe eight minutes
of that movie.
It was,
oh man,
it was a
dude.
When,
when,
when fucking what now to fuck's his name when he takes Rob Lowe's head and he
stuffs it in a fucking toilet in a bar and he,
the guy doesn't get mad.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
whatever the wet look is in.
I'm like,
okay,
all right.
And then for the third time they did the,
they all told a joke and they all went,
but I'm bumping.
Then they had that little fucking thing that day when we get it,
they have comradery,
their college friends.
I was just like,
all right.
Um,
plus basically everybody who had this look on their face that they were just
really enjoying being famous.
I don't think it was a good time for any of those actors cause I like all the
actors in that movie.
But that was just like they had that look on their face like,
yeah,
this is never going end.
Um,
not all of them.
Okay.
MMM.
Anyway,
so I shut that one off and I was like,
all right,
I'm not,
you know,
this is actually gonna make the flight seem longer.
So then the last movie I watched,
what the hell that I watch?
I just went blank.
I watched another really good one.
This is how my brain's work,
cause I literally knew the movie and then I thought,
wait,
what was the one previous to it?
And then if I go previous it just a racist.
The last thought,
oh,
I remember.
Yeah.
I watched,
uh,
what happened to baby
Jane Starting
Bette Davis and uh,
I don't want to say that Joan Collins,
the other Joan,
let me see.
Bette Davis and Joan Crawford and I always heard that,
you know,
they did a whole movie about how they didn't fucking like each other and all of
this type of shit.
I watched that movie.
That's one of those movies that's,
it's like the performances and everything.
I really good.
Then it keeps going out off the road and then it comes back.
There is sort of a major hole in it where you know some shit that happened
before you get to see them.
It's like,
and the cops didn't intervene and then they were cool with the two of them just
hanging out.
Is,
is that,
does that what happened?
All this studio fixed it?
Um,
yeah.
I actually really enjoyed it and there's an APP sure.
In it who I really fucking loved and it turned out I'm going to get his name
here.
It turned out that,
uh,
he actually was the one that played King Tut on the Batman series.
It was a phenomenal actor.
I was like,
who the fuck is that guy?
What's his name?
Oh,
for fuck sakes.
Is it Victor Buono?
Is that how you say his name?
Yes.
Larger than life.
Yeah.
In with an eloquent king size appetite from maniacal Mariemont.
Who the fuck wrote this shit?
Um,
Jesus Christ,
he didn't live long ago,
died at 43.
That must've been the old heart attack.
Take people trying to get the weight off,
try to keep the,
get the weight up and try and keep it off.
Don't need a bunch of fucking candy like I did.
So anyways,
I recommend all of those movies.
Um,
and I guess saint almost fired too if you're doing some research on the brat
pack now.
If I was going to watch a Brat pack movie,
I would watch the breakfast club.
I think that that was the high water mark of that.
But a saint almost fire if wasn't a good one.
Um hmm.
Oh,
the other ones about last night.
What was the one that had Andrew McCarthy and rob Lowe and they both went to
college
and uh,
I,
I know I can't,
I can't talk about the movie without given the fucking thing away,
but it has one of the most anticlimactic endings to a movie I've ever seen.
I'm not ripping either after,
cause I think they did a good job,
but it's just like,
did they just improv the end of that fucking thing?
Um,
I don't want to ruin that one.
All right.
What am I fucking Siskel and Ebert here?
Shut the fuck up bill,
whatever.
That's what I,
that's what I watched.
Then I got home.
Okay.
Finally got home,
uh,
at about three 34 in the morning.
And uh,
I was able to,
uh,
yesterday sleep a little bit.
Right now it's four in the morning.
My time,
I,
uh,
was able to stay up til about four in the afternoon yesterday going to watch the
Celtics game.
I was like,
I'm gonna close my eyes for an hour.
And I woke up at eight and I was like,
ah,
fuck.
Um,
because a pipe burst in my house,
shout out to my wife,
handling that whole fucking thing.
I'm one of the main things you can greatest things you can ever teach your wife
is how to shut off the fucking water in your house before major water damage
gets done.
And she handled that like a champ by a time she woke me up.
The plumbers were already there and they fixed it.
So I don't know.
As I've set,
this house has a lot of character.
It's got a lot of character,
everybody,
a lot of fucking character.
MMM.
Run and hide.
If anybody ever says that of a house that you're thinking about buying.
All right.
But the Boston Bruins and your North Carolina hurricanes are getting ready to
show first game tonight,
5:00 PM west coast time,
8:00 PM east coast time.
Fucking 7:00 PM central time and 6:00 PM mountain tack that I handle everything.
What time is it in Hawaii?
I don't know.
Probably starts at like fucking one in the afternoon to have the afternoon.
Honolulu time
[inaudible]
uh,
four o'clock,
Alaska time.
Uh,
the Bruins start that series with the very difficult Caroline hurricanes have no
idea.
I don't know anything about this team other than that they've been an absolute
buzz saw sets to be getting of April.
So this should be another tough one.
Um,
I don't why they give it Marshawn shit for that little fucking snarky fucking
report or given them a rough time.
Somebody tried to it to how I,
I missed the whole series.
Charlie Mcavoy,
I guess,
uh,
had a hit that was up high,
possibly dirty,
you know,
hit against somebody on the Columbus blue jackets.
He's like,
and they're still able to shake hands.
Why doesn't Brad Marshawn,
uh,
give more than one word answers to this fucking jerk off reporter because he's
not on the ice.
That's why he's not a player.
Yeah.
Stop paying.
This guy wrote this whole fucking article.
Like the reporters are just like,
people wouldn't even know what was going on.
We totally would know what was going on.
We're not there for your report.
Were there for the game?
We're watching the fucking game.
People would still watch literally if there was no fucking announces,
it wouldn't be as good,
would not be as good.
All right.
But I would say right now that the level of coverage,
it's,
it's so above and beyond anything that's even needed.
Where did that,
where did that fucking thing even happen?
It happened during the warmups before a fucking playoff game in Marshawn took
time out of warming up for a crucial fucking play off game
to talk to this fucking asshole.
And then he starts giving him shit like he's actually picked sides and he skated
away like he should have.
Okay.
I liked what he did and I liked that he gave one word answers,
but of course the press is always going to have the last answer and then they're
going to bring up,
you know,
you look a few faces,
couple of so,
so forth.
So the next thing you know,
you can never get a break in the press,
but that's just how it is.
That's just how it is.
But all I know is that Brad Mars and the Boston Bruins have moved onto the
eastern conference finals and that fucking report,
it has not,
someone's going to hoist the trophy this year,
the Stanley Cup,
and they're going to skate around.
When am I going to tell you one person who isn't that fucking guy and me?
So why don't you shut the fuck up with your little snarky?
He didn't,
if he just asked him about the play,
then he goes,
hey,
did you get your skates sharpened?
He sounded like a fucking blue jacket fin.
So fuck that guy.
Fuck his Instagram.
And all that shit.
Not saying to go on it and trash them cause that's,
that's even worse.
That's even worse than what I'm doing here on the podcast.
Um,
so being jet lagged,
I was able to get caught up with some of the moto GP although I haven't a
problem with their fucking uh,
their website.
I guess they haven't uploaded the um,
the replay of the uh,
yeah
the race from Spain yet.
But I was able to watch the one from Austin,
Texas where Mark Marquez was in turn 12,
which I guess is a difficult term because you come down from that straightaway
and you've got to slow go from sixth gear all the way down to first gear.
And I dunno what happened.
They kept saying trailbreaking I'm not a motorcycle guy.
I tried to be that guy for fucking two months out here in la.
And all I kept thinking about was the time Richie Cunningham got the motorcycle
and Fonzie was telling him not to get it and then he ended up having a fucking
accident cause know what he was a car guy.
What are the most dangerous things out there if you're riding a motorcycle
beyond people texting.
All right.
Is,
is while they're driving is to have a car guy on a motorcycle.
And I,
I was able to recognize that in myself.
So anyways,
um,
there was nobody near him and he just fucking wiped up.
They just wiped out and then couldn't get the bike started and um,
and he got no championship points so it was huge obviously for them to get a win
here.
And He,
I think he's right.
I think he's back up by one cause to,
he also had a,
uh,
oh no,
I'm confusing racist.
Viteos I had a great start in the,
uh,
the Austin one and they did a little,
a little bit of blue,
blue,
blue and the fucking first turn.
And then that was it for him the whole fucking day.
I still don't understand why,
how I do like it.
I think what makes motorcycle racing interesting to me is the south certain
bikes or just why are certain bikes better in the corners,
in other bikes are better on the straightaway.
Is it simply the way that they have them set up or is it literally,
hey,
we're just make it a better fucking engine for this thing?
Is it how I always hear like how I've missed the glory days of Formula One cars.
Now the cars are two evenly matched and it's all about racing to the first turn.
Whoever's gets to the first turn and then the ones who win the fucking thing.
That seems to be what happens in Formula One.
Um,
but,
uh,
I was not able to watch the last f one race,
which I'm going to watch here now at like four in the morning when I finish this
podcast.
And I believe Lewis Hamilton is just a,
I think he won that one again.
I mean,
I don't know this,
it's literally just like which Mercedes drivers gonna win it this year or more
accurately.
Does Valtteri Botox have a run in him to stop the inevitable?
Um,
so I'm going to go upstairs.
I'm going to fucking watch that when I get done recording.
This thing had to go downstairs into the La version of a basement and a record
this thing,
cause I don't want to wake up my lovely daughter who I had not seen in fucking
eight days,
crushed me.
Right.
And I came home and uh,
she woke up early or whatever and I was psyched because I was up and I went in
there to get her up and I was waiting to see your beautiful face light up that,
oh my God,
I'm seeing,
I'm seeing Daddy.
Right.
And I came in and she big smile on her face and the first thing she said to me
was,
I want Mama.
So I just left,
you know,
got her up,
change there at all,
that type of stuff.
And then,
um,
it's unreal.
I hate me in a way like that.
Uh,
but I did,
I did bring everybody to Iceland and we had an amazing week there.
So I mean,
and you know what,
this is how I keep the lights on.
So I do have to,
you know,
go out and go to work.
Plumber has to go out and fix the fucking sinks.
And I have to go out and go tell my jokes.
I will tell you though,
uh,
just being away a week,
she got even taller and now she can like put her Pajama top on herself all by
herself.
She can move her arm around and get through the sleeve and it's just like Jesus
Christ go away for a weekly.
They grow by leaps and bounds.
So,
um,
anyway,
I got her out of bed and,
uh,
you know,
stiff as hell from being on the plane.
So I said,
she goes,
let's go see Mama.
And I said,
all right,
well hang on a second.
I've got to stretch for first.
So what's hilarious is when I do my stretches,
she doesn't with me.
And then she imitates the noises that I make.
So like I did like the forward bend,
you know,
to start yoga,
you grab your elbows or whatever to afford Ben and I,
you know,
when I got passed,
basically certain levels,
like,
ah,
and then she does hers and she goes,
Ah,
she just imitating,
she laughed.
She thinks I'm being funny rather than just being old.
So,
mmm.
She comes into the bedroom now and she takes the foam roller and she puts it
down and she sits down on it and have the her height.
It's like a little chair and she sits down on and she's going,
ah,
uh,
thinking that like,
that's what you're supposed to do,
whether the,
uh,
whether it hurts or not.
Uh,
she's the best and I'm home for a little bit before,
uh,
I have an act of Gig,
that's shoots this entire summer.
I don't know.
I think they already,
they already put some stuff out about,
uh,
it's,
I usually tell jokes and shit about the shit that I'm in,
but I'm actually in a,
uh,
Pete Davidson movie,
vehicle that,
that Judd Apatow and all those guys.
So I'm very excited to be in this thing and,
um,
I got to eat perfectly here for the next few weeks,
be in the the right kind of shape.
You know what's great though is when you are my agent succeptible to acceptable
level to be in a certain level of shape.
You know,
he's 50,
I'm turned 51 in this fucking shoe.
Um,
anyways,
by the way,
it's mother's Day.
It is mother's Day.
Everybody coming up this Sunday.
Don't forget.
Um,
let me read a little bit of advertising here and then that'll be it.
Tiara,
right?
Dollar Shave Club to food.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best and you never have to go to the store.
Uh Oh after,
after I'm done reading these things,
I'm going to tell you about my show in Israel and Tel Aviv specifically.
That's because they deliver everything you need right to your door and they keep
you fully stocked on what you use so you don't run out.
Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you need to get ready no matter what you're
getting ready for.
They have you covered head to toe for your hair,
your skin,
your face,
you name it,
they have it.
And they have this new program where they automatically keep you stocked up on
the products you use.
You determine what you want,
when you want it and it shows up right at your door from once a month to once
every six months.
Plus with their hands some discount.
The more you buy,
the more you save.
And Right now dollar shave club has a bunch of starters sets you can get for
just $5 like their oral care kit.
Ladies after that,
the restock box ships regular sized products at regular price.
Get you start a set for just $5 right now with dollar shave club.com/burr that's
dollar shave
club.com/burr all right,
legal zoom.
Running a small business is a lot of work.
It takes time and money and you want all the time and money you have to go to
towards growing your business.
But what happens when legal hurdles pop up along the way?
Legal Zoom is there to help.
Nearly 2 million Americans have used legal zoom to start their businesses with
LLCs and corporations in more.
But even after your business is set up,
legal zoom can still help out.
Things like lease agreements,
changing tax laws and contract reviews are all part of running your own
business.
And these are precisely the kinds of costly hurdles that can take time away from
growing your business.
That's why legal zoom created their bis business legal plan.
Get advice for running your business from vetted independent attorneys and tax
professionals available in all 50 states.
The best part is you don't.
You won't get charged by the hour.
Since legalzoom isn't a law firm,
make your tea.
Make your time and money work for you.
Check out legal zoom is business legal zoom,
wait,
checkout,
legal zooms business legal plan at legal,
zoom.com a lot of legal in there now and get special savings when you enter
borough checkout legal zoom where life meets legal legal zoom.com and one more
for Ya.
Oh,
zip.
Hey,
up.
Hiring used to be hot hiring used to be had multiple job sites,
stacks of resumes,
a confusing review process.
But today hiring can be easy and you only have to go to one place to get it
done.
That's all zip.
Yeah.
[inaudible] dot com slash bird ZipRecruiter sends your job to over 100 of the
web's leading job boards,
but they don't stop there with their powerful matching technologies.
Yep.
Yeah.
Scans thousands of resumes to find people with the right experience,
invites them to apply to your job as applications come in.
Zip recruiter analyzes each one and spotlights the top candidates.
So you never miss a great match.
Sip
that is so effective that four out of five employees who post on Sec.
Yeah.
Get a quality candidate through the site within the first day.
And right now my listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free for an exclusive web
address.
SIP recruiter.com/bird that
ziprecruiter.com/bar.
Spell it out Zip,
r e C R U,
I t e r.com/ [inaudible].
That's [inaudible]
the smartest way to hire.
All right.
Um,
I did a show in Tel Aviv.
I actually recorded the show.
Uh,
hopefully it didn't take the audio straight from the board.
I don't know if it's been miked up,
but I just wanted to hear,
I just had a feeling I was going to have,
it was just going to be one of those.
Um,
yeah,
sometimes you just,
you just,
you just feel it,
you know,
not saying that the others ones weren't.
And I think the last time I talked to you,
I just done Helsinki,
which was amazing.
Oslow was crazy fucking crazy show.
I had close to six or 7,000 people show up and then we went to,
um,
we went to us podcast is going to go a little long.
Then we went to Amsterdam.
MMM.
And that was like 3,500 people couldn't believe like that.
Many fucking people showed up other side of the world just to hear my fucking
shit.
And Dick Jokes was amazing.
And um,
we went out in a Oslow went out and I smoked a cigar and I fricking cigar
smoking is off the rails.
I really got to reel that in.
You know,
I feel like in a way that I kind of replaced the fact that I wasn't drinking,
which was hard when I was going through Europe.
So all of a sudden I'm fucking eating candy bars and smoking cigarettes,
fucking craziness,
just because I'm addicted to some sort of buzz at the end of the day.
So once I,
I have to fucking get back to what I was doing,
which was putting on my pj's and fucking reading the book,
which I would have done,
cause I was,
I have like 25 more pages to go in that Beastie boy book,
but it was the cover special edition.
So it was like sticking a fucking extra laptop in my bag and I didn't want to
check a bag so I didn't bring it.
So
okay,
I should have brought like this paper back book.
Somebody got me on the Simpsons or something like that and done that instead.
But I didn't.
So now I have to live with my decisions.
Um,
so any who I um,
yeah,
let me see what was that?
Oh yes.
So also we ended up going out when we went on a slow
Oslo,
is that,
are you saying?
And uh,
they took us out to this,
this bar.
It was funny.
It was freezing cold out.
We walked home and they were going,
yeah,
just to let you know,
you know,
cause they want you,
you want to take a cab or it's just like a six,
five,
six minute walk.
But like,
oh it's walk and we get out and it was freezing out and the guy goes,
hey,
just let you know this is the bad part of town.
Like a lot of people don't like coming down to this part of town.
It's like,
well you know,
you probably should have said that,
you know,
five minutes ago when we were deciding how we were going to get home so they
have a walking and it was just like,
I don't know.
I mean there was definitely some drunk people there didn't seem to fucking crazy
credit.
I was only in that part of time for five minutes and who really mugged somebody
on a freezing cold night.
You know,
I always feel like people that Mug,
people like,
Hey,
I'm going to fucking stay in tonight.
You know,
put on my pj's and read a book on a Mug.
People better,
you know,
mugging for dummies,
whatever the fuck they would read.
Then I went to a,
went to Amsterdam the next day,
um,
eight at this amazing fucking egg place that was right down the street.
They had a gourmet chicken sandwich,
one of those places.
I ordered it and like,
I'm sorry we sold,
we were sold out of that sandwich.
You're like,
ah,
this is one of these ads in places.
Right.
It was delicious.
If you're going to Amsterdam,
send me an email and I'll let you know what the fuck it is cause I don't have
the information with me right now.
Um,
I can show,
can just find it on fucking if you just Google it.
God knows.
That's how I found it.
And then I went to,
uh,
we went out to,
I forget the name of the place,
there was just some bar where you could just go in and you can just order weed
and smoke some weed.
And so if they had milkshakes too.
So I said I'd fuck it.
So may Barton equated in there and I am not a big weed guy and I'm still not.
And uh,
I dunno,
this was this body high shit.
So I smoked it and I was just like,
I'm not high.
I don't feel high right now.
And I think it was cause it was a body high cause the next day I woke up and I
definitely feel like,
you know,
something happened.
So I dunno.
I Dunno if I,
I guess I was,
I don't know.
All I know is I enjoyed the shit out of that fucking milkshake.
And it also took me,
like I asked for a vanilla milkshake
and then the woman showed up and she goes,
when she brought the orders like did you ask for Vanilla or strawberry?
I can't remember.
It's like,
yeah,
because everybody's smoking weed in here.
And I was,
and I looked at it and it looked like a vanilla shake cause it was all white.
Said I stepped.
I go,
yeah,
no that's,
that's,
that's vanilla.
And it wasn't till I was like three quarters of the way through.
Then it Kinda got to the clump of the ice of it,
that,
uh,
the clump of the milkshake,
you know,
it's all stuck together.
That's it.
I guess we're,
all the strawberries were,
I dunno,
I dunno.
But that was sort of interesting.
I,
I gotta be honest with you though,
Dude.
I just,
I'm not into it.
I'm just not into weed.
I'm just like,
I don't know.
I just,
I don't like sitting around like,
hey man,
like I'm just like,
fucking chill in here,
man.
I'm not fucking,
not,
I would rather smoke a cigar and a then just sit there,
which is an obnoxious thing to do.
Um,
I will tell you though,
if,
uh,
if you are a single person,
you know,
and you got a little bit of fucking time off,
I mean,
that part of the world's a great place to go.
Norway and Finland,
the women,
but just fucking gorgeous particulars and they just have like regular jobs
because there's so many of them.
You know,
you literally order room service.
You're looking at this woman,
it's like you would be reading the national news and my country,
oh that say they're all like that,
but Jesus Christ man was,
you know,
I don't know.
I feel like a troll when I'm walking around over there.
So then lastly,
but leastly uh,
we did our show and Tel Aviv and man,
I just had this feeling,
I was like,
I just got a feeling that show's going to be one of those shows.
And uh,
and it was,
it was like,
um,
I feel like the last three shows Norway,
Amsterdam and then something happened when I was in,
uh,
yeah,
when I was in Helsinki where I was just like,
all right,
yeah,
just whatever.
Just do what you always do.
Whatever the joke you think can just do that one next.
Cause I was really doing this rigorous,
like I must dump my last hour of material and I must do all of these new bits
that I have and the new bits of working,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't be doing them.
People paid money to see me,
but there was no flow to them.
It was kind of like the Celtics this year.
I'm always fucking ideas,
but it was just like the,
the,
you know,
the transitions were a little awkward and I sat,
fuck this,
I'm just going to just do my shit.
And it just kind of came to a peak when I went to a Tel Aviv and it just could
not have been a better fucking crowd.
And I,
you know,
found out when I was over there that like 10% of their population doesn't even
fucking pay taxes.
And from what I can understand,
it was the Jewish people who dress up like,
like the,
uh,
sort of the pilgrim look without the buckle on the front and the curly Q hair on
the side.
I don't know if it's every one of them,
but it was just like,
dude,
what the fuck?
How the fuck?
Especially
in Israel,
he can't kick in for a little bit of something to defend your people at that.
That's just,
you know,
I don't get that at all because God knows this.
People in my country doing the same fucking thing,
making billions and billions and millions of fucking dollars,
and they don't pay any fucking taxes.
And then nobody goes after them.
And then when the bill comes in,
Oh,
it's a little higher there all week we got a tax.
The people that are already the honest people already pay in taxes.
We got to tax them more.
And what kills me is people who make less money are like,
yeah,
that's the solution.
Nobody goes,
oh,
we got to go after these fucking freeloading.
So anyways,
I made fun of that.
Uh,
came right out,
opened with that.
So I was just like,
all right,
I got to see,
you know where,
where,
where these people are at.
I did a Hitler joke that also killed.
And as an aside,
these fucking people are cool and we just,
I just had like the best fucking time and a,
afterwards I met like I think just about every comedian in Israel,
we did a group photo and we were having a great time and this woman kept saying,
all right,
get out.
Leave him alone.
I said,
they're not bothering me.
And then she goes,
yes,
they are.
It's like,
Oh,
I'm sorry,
I didn't realize you're more in touch with,
I should've put my foot down and spend like lady lady.
They're not,
they're not relax,
relax.
Okay.
They're not bothered.
I'm not just being nice.
I like meeting comedians.
Um,
so anyway,
uh,
I met them and then when I walked outside there was all these people hanging out
and um,
you know,
I took all these pictures.
I met some guy from Turkey,
came down from Turkey just to see my act,
which is so flattering.
It was another woman there who was like,
I dunno,
like it looked like,
you know,
seven,
eight months pregnant,
you know,
took time to come out to the show is just one of those nights.
And,
uh,
Afterwards me Barnet and club Soda Kenny,
like we didn't,
we didn't want the night to end,
so we'd already smoked like two of the best cigars I've,
I've ever had.
There was this right next to my hotel,
there was like this little like Bodega that sold everything from fucking m and
m's and ice cream
and beer and wine too.
Fucking then they had Cuban cigars.
Yeah.
And I don't know what that little humidors system was,
but they smell the drawn on was incredible.
So the first day we smoked a a,
I can't remember we talked about this,
cause I know I recorded the afternoon of the show.
The first one we smoked was a,
uh,
it was a Cohiba robusto and then the next day it was,
I don't know if you say part part,
I guess a partake us.
We smoked the a,
the series d,
which is their version,
I think of a robusto and there was two of the best fucking cigars.
And we just were sitting there
right on,
uh,
Jaffa beach sitting on a park bench watching people go by and,
you know,
there was a church,
what are they,
what do they call it?
They don't call it,
is it a synagogue?
A temple?
Uh,
some do would just,
I don't know,
on the hour or whatever would start singing in fucking say Hebrew.
Okay.
You'd just be sitting there,
right?
Like,
you weren't getting enough for the fucking vibe of Israel.
All of a sudden this guy would just,
yeah.
Oh,
hey,
a holiday.
I was just like,
I can't do it.
Um,
and me bar,
they would just look at each other and smile like they were in fucking Israel.
We just sat there looking at the beautiful Mediterranean Sea smoking this cigar
so that later on that night,
or like,
what do you want to do is I really want to smoke another cigar.
It's like,
dude,
I can't,
I've already broke my rule of not smoking a cigar before is shown.
I did that fucking throat is on fire here.
So,
uh,
I went,
did that Bodega and I just got a little thing,
ice cream,
fucking hilarious.
Three big meat heads walking down the beach,
eating ice cream,
you know,
at like fucking 10 30 at night.
Uh,
and just sat.
They just went over the whole tour in our heads,
just talking about,
um,
you know,
just how much fun we had and what a fucking experience it was.
We went all the way back to like,
dude,
remember when we were Reykjavik Iceland,
meeting all those comedians and going up there and that,
that one Icelandic comedian with the crazy laugh,
he had this love like,
how the fuck was,
I can't remember.
It's just like,
it's crazy.
Fucking laugh.
And then he went on stage and he was funny as hell.
MMM.
And listening to them talking about the secret seller and their whole comedy
thing and,
and uh,
and then we were off Copenhagen,
Stockholm,
Finland,
and then the rest of the ones I just talked about,
it could,
it just was just really one of those fucking tours.
And I gotta be honest with you,
I'm starting to think like,
I like to traveling internationally to do stand up.
Like I don't have to deal with,
like I do stand up now in the states and it's just like,
what do you get off stage?
Like what the fuck did I say it?
What's going to be taken seriously that I'd go too far on that one.
Is that going to be some sort of fucking issue?
And um,
I don't know.
It's probably why I went so over the top of my latest special coming out and
also why I love the new Nick Depaulo special that's out.
You know,
and I don't agree with everything that the guy says,
but just the fact that someone can get out there and just fucking say what
they're thinking anyways.
And I know there's going to be a bunch of people in the labs are going to be
doing and get gig again.
It's like you tell me the difference between that fucking special that far to
the right in some of these other specials that far to the left.
You know that you get to the point where it's just people just on stage saying
liberal agenda.
There's,
there's no laughing people that just applause break.
Uh,
the younger comics funny as hell.
They told me they call it those comics.
They go on stage and they get clapped her,
nobody's fucking laughing.
So this is the answer to that.
And it's like,
if you don't want somebody going that hard and the other side,
then you,
you,
you know,
it's gotten fucking crazy.
Like people need to sort of meet in the middle and,
and listen to each other and respect the fact that we're all fucking living here
and that people have different views on things rather than just being like,
which I'll never,
never my life that I ever think that I would see the left get to the fucking
point where it's just like save what we say,
think what we think.
And if you don't,
we're going to destroy your fucking career.
I was actually reading,
you know,
cause I,
just watching those old movies
okay.
And uh,
watching Joan Crawford and Bette Davis,
you know,
then you start looking them up and then they'll,
they'll show like Lauren Bacall and all these great,
uh,
Ingrid Bergman and all these great actresses from back in the day.
And I think it was Lauren Bacall had thing seeing how she was liberal and saying
being a liberal is the greatest thing that this isn't like the 1940s or 50s.
Being a liberal is the greatest thing that you can be.
It makes you open minded and,
um,
accepting of others.
And just,
and I was,
I was just shaking my head going,
yeah,
that's what it used to be.
MMM.
I don't know.
I don't think it was always that because I always do think that.
I don't think that,
um,
I don't know,
back when I was growing up,
I mean,
politicians have always been filthy,
but like they had like that,
that they kind of enjoyed the back and forth.
It wasn't as nasty as it is now,
but,
but whatever,
you just listened to a guy who doesn't even fucking watch the news and miss most
of the sporting events.
But tonight I got a little bit of rehearsal for that film.
I'm going to start the game a little bit late,
but,
uh,
go Bruins is always,
and I'm looking forward to another great series.
Congratulations to the Columbus blue jackets.
On a phenomenal season.
Congratulations to the Milwaukee Bucks.
Moving on.
I'm going to enjoy watching you guys.
Uh,
I think I'm going to,
uh,
maybe I'll root for the bucks.
I Dunno.
I saw Duran,
thank God Warrenton blow out as Achilles.
That's like the fucking worst for a basketball or any,
any athletes.
So it's just calf strain.
So,
uh,
she may be watched the rest of that series.
God knows I got nothing to do and I'm really tempted to fill up all my free time
with going out and flying a fucking helicopter.
But,
uh,
I've learned that that adds stress.
Drains me when I fill up all everything in my life and then I fucking stuck
getting upset and then people suffer,
so I got to stop fucking doing that shit.
So I think will only fly like twice instead of 40 types of,
whenever I am wired the way I'm wired.
I'm doing the goddamn comedy jam on Monday.
The last show
at the,
uh,
Jesus Christ.
What's the name of the fucking venue at the Roxy?
Monday.
Uh,
[inaudible]
May 13th at 9:00 PM,
and,
uh,
I got to get this song together.
I'm,
I'm playing a song that's just a wait.
Yeah,
May 13th.
I'm playing,
I'm playing a song as always,
I'm,
I'm always reaching beyond unless I play like highway to hell.
I even then,
you know,
that song is not as easy as you'd think as far as just playing something that's
simple and making it sound good.
So I am reaching beyond my ability.
So,
uh,
let's see.
I'm waiting for this thing to fucking load here.
All I can see is the other two names.
They,
it says Jeff Ross in Mas.
So that's obviously Jeb,
Ronnie Mazda,
Bronnie,
Jeff Ross,
myself,
Josh,
Adam Meyers is wonderful band.
And uh,
this'll be the last one at the Roxy Theater.
I think they've actually maybe outgrown it and they're going to move onto a
bigger venue.
Okay.
So,
uh,
I'm gonna be down there,
try out my new jokes,
forcing them down your throats,
and then I'm going to get up and make a fool of myself.
Playing drums is always,
it's going to be be a,
it's gotta be a great time.
I hope to rose is going to be there.
I'm not sure if he is.
Why won't this fucking thing
tell me who's on the lineup.
Oh,
there it is.
Uh,
they got the name of the fucking promoters on there.
Come on.
Who else is going to be on this fucking thing?
Look at me.
It's so early in the morning.
Can actually do an hour here on the Thursday podcast.
All it has is the names of the promoters.
Oh Man,
look at that cheeseburger.
Jesus the Internet.
They just know.
They fucking know they,
they,
that's why they want to have the cookies everywhere.
So they,
we see what he's into and I make it and that fucking patriots jacket,
I'm not going to buy it.
I feel like if I finally by that thing,
when I click,
you know,
the paypal to pay for it,
the my computer is going to go.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
We knew you couldn't resist.
For those of you who haven't been listening to podcasts.
I,
I went on Mitchell and ness.
I love that website even though I look like a jerk off and all of their fucking,
you know,
all of their fucking stuff just because I'm an old guy here.
But,
uh,
I looked up,
I was,
this is patriots jacket that I wanted when I was a little kid and I still,
I,
I finally found it,
um,
and who made it,
but uh,
they discontinued it.
It was a cheap jacket anyways,
the sleeves look leather,
but I believe there was some sort of vinyl and then it was supposed to be sort
of a wool,
you know,
it's like a varsity jacket and the jacket part that fit around like a
bulletproof vest,
that part of the jacket is,
uh,
was supposed to be wool,
but it was this pillowy cheap fucking,
the whole thing was a mess.
Um,
but I went on Mitchell and ness first to see if they had done a version of the
jacket and they didn't.
And I looked at some patriots jackets and I swear to God,
this was like fucking two months ago,
60 days ago,
and they won't let up.
They won't let up,
which means somebody at least 60 days in that they just kept showing the ad to
finally clicked and said,
yeah,
I'm going to buy that fucking thing.
How hilarious is that?
Oh,
advertising.
All right.
That's it.
Thank you to everybody came out to my shows.
I'm back here in the US.
Um,
I'm going to watch the Bruins tonight and,
um,
I think Joe Rogan is out of the ice house.
If I get a fucking second wind,
we'll see.
We'll see.
I might be too fucking tired.
Um,
I'm not officially on that fucking show,
but there's a chance I might,
I might drop by.
I shouldn't say that because I most likely won't.
All right.
There's the oldest and most likely won't,
but right now and fucking 4:37 AM I'm feeling like I can fucking do that to take
a little cat nap.
All right.
That said,
go fuck yourselves.
Have a great weekend and I'll talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible] on one
on its bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 9th,
2011.
How the hell are you guys?
Yeah,
that's fucking great.
I'm here at the,
uh,
k rock studios this week.
A very special,
very special edition of the Monday morning podcast because I'm doing this huge
comedy tour that Jim Norton put together.
What's stars?
Jimmy Norton.
David Tell Jim Breuer and myself the antisocial network tour and we are hyping
the date.
Uh,
May 13th we're going to be in DC,
a Dar constitution hall or some Shit.
I Dunno.
I Dunno why.
That's Omar laughing in the background.
He's going to,
he's going to be doing the a actually working the boards.
People have always complained about how awful your levels,
my levels are.
You know what I like to do,
I like to take the base and turn it all the way down and then just crank up the
high end so it makes people's ears bleed.
Absolutely.
That sets what I go.
It's,
so anyways,
we're going to be hyping that this week.
Jim Norton is actually going to call in.
David tell is going to call in.
Jim Breuer was actually too busy.
So whenever we got two out of three,
you know,
one of the biggest tours out there,
uh,
as I've said before,
the sort of the Miami heat of comedy tours or possibly the Ocean's 11 if seven
of them died tragically and then four decided to carry on and do a fucking
comedy show.
So anyways,
I will waiting for Jim Norton to call in at this moment.
So while Miss,
do what I always do,
I'm going to riff Omar.
If I look at you and I looked panicked and I'm feeling fucking nuts,
we'll refer a little bit,
but until then,
just act like I'm not even here.
Let's just make this is fucking weird as humanly possible.
Comfortable.
Um,
somebody who is,
let's see what is going on.
Let's wait.
What are we going to start with this week?
Why don't we start talking about sports everybody.
Huh?
The fucking Bruins finished off the goddamn filthy flyers,
which made me feel good.
And for all flyer fans out there,
I'm not even gonna Talk Shit.
I'm not even gonna gloat because a,
I was beyond nervous when we were up three games to none,
uh,
because of what happened to us last year.
And I was actually,
I was actually praying,
not praying.
I was kinda hoping on some level that you guys would win one of the first three
games.
So,
so even if we lost the series,
it wouldn't again be from fucking being up three games to none.
So I have to admit,
I don't know if you noticed,
but when you guys tied up game for one one,
did you notice how quiet the fucking garden got?
So,
uh,
we were all nervous about that shit,
but uh,
that's it man.
Enjoy your golf and go fuck yourselves with your little fucking cream sickle
uniforms.
It's over.
It's fucking over for you once again.
And hopefully we won't be right behind you cause I'm fucking nervous about
playing Tampa Bay because they have a,
they got three cons on that team that can put the biscuit in the basket as they
say.
And I'm really,
uh,
I don't know,
fucking know.
It's the bro Wins,
you know what I mean?
Every time you get excited and you're like,
you know how that,
this might be the year,
this could be it.
Oh,
speaking of filthy fliers,
what about that bullshit at the end of the game?
Was it because we get,
we scored two empty net goals that you decided to give Patrice Bergeron a mild
concussion.
The basic,
the Jason Kidd of our fucking team.
Is that what you had to do?
I'm really happy that,
what's his face?
Uh,
Josh Hart and I'll actually shaved off all that fucking hair that he had.
I really hated that home.
Mac Davis looked that he was rocking and I couldn't,
I got to admit,
I didn't even notice him in the,
in the series.
I think he's like Thor.
Like he cut off his fucking hit.
Who's the guy you pick if you cut off his fucking hair?
Uh,
Samson.
He said,
Samson,
are you one of those comic book nerds who will get into all this?
Fuck,
no.
I,
you asked me anything about comic books.
I don't know.
Have any clue.
Yeah.
All these fucking movies,
Thor.
I mean,
how much are you scraping the bottom of the barrel when you're down to the guy
who has a hammer?
He's got this fucking hammer,
Eddie,
he and,
and that's all his power and then fucking his dad throws it down to the earth.
Like I gotta admit,
I understand that me being into sports at the level of Matt and the fact that I
don't even play is roughly the same thing I guess.
But at least sports is real.
The fuck is wrong with you guys,
with you.
God Damn Thor wallpaper and Flash Pajamas and they've now how many,
how many fucking good movies do they even make with the superhero movies?
Honestly,
did you guys really like Spiderman?
Where you really into that?
Where they,
uh,
they gave him a girlfriend with those little teeth,
remember that,
and he's fucking kissing her upside.
They turned it into a fucking love story.
So they could get you to bring your fucking broad down to the movie theater.
Spiderman did not have a not good looking or a mediocre,
whoever the fuck played his wife.
And those movies,
I would not be nervous approaching in a bar and that there's something wrong
with that being a balding redhead.
Okay.
There's something wrong.
I should be,
I should be beyond nervous.
But I wasn't.
I remember when I saw the fucking movie,
I remember thinking,
where's the raven haired big hip,
big titty girlfriend that he had in the,
in the comic books.
And she was nowhere to be found.
Kirsten Dunst.
That's what it was with their little toddler teeth sitting there smiling at him.
She was awful.
She looked like six a picture you'd see in like one of those,
uh,
one of those fairy tales.
The fables,
you know,
be like the girlfriend ambient to mean to her.
I was going to say the fucking girlfriend of the troll under the bridge.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
this is probably odd to the actually have them hearing you laughing in the
background.
Usually it's just me sort of like babbling in the bedroom.
You know what?
Yeah,
bring that down.
Just so,
because you know,
people learn the fucking internet no matter what,
they're going to trash.
The poor kids shook.
What the fuck was that Guy Giggling in the background for him.
I'm gonna have to deal with all of that,
all of that horseshit.
So,
uh,
like I said,
when I look at you in a moment of panic,
like I don't know where the fuck this is going to be going.
Uh,
for the love of God.
Bring up your mic and a and save me.
But I,
like I said,
we're sitting here,
we're waiting for a,
for the legendary Jim Norton Star of I was actually looking at is IMDP page and
a,
I didn't realize all this shit that this guy has done.
He just recently did a spot on bored to death,
a hit television show,
I believe on Hbo or showtime.
He's a bestselling author.
He's got two books.
Happy endings.
I hate your guts.
He's got a brand new CD out called despicable available.
Look at me.
I'm hyping is shit before he even gets on the goddamn phone,
by the way.
Um,
when,
when I gave him the phone number to call in there they are gonna it's going to
light up here,
right?
I'll see you.
The phone numbers are going to light up.
Okay.
I'm just making sure.
All right.
This takes me back to the days I used to do a show back with the teen idols
sensation from the,
and Anthony showed
Judd Joe de Rosa.
I used to do a show,
we used to try to take callers and he's still always be a fucking nightmare.
So,
um,
this is actually taken me back.
You know,
we used to actually do this show called uninformed that we're trying desperately
to bring back.
The problem is,
is that we live on opposite coasts.
I don't know if we can tie in Skype.
We got to figure out a fucking way to do that.
Um,
but we used to take callers and because it was a brand new show,
we might as well been like on like,
like public access.
We just go like,
hey,
we're talking about a apple trees.
Anybody want to call in on that?
And then we would just have fucking callers call in,
wait what?
Talking about apple trees and you pick it up.
Hey,
why don't you go fuck yourself,
you fag.
And then they'd hang up on us.
So we stopped taking collars and I learned my lesson.
So this,
um,
this week I'm just going to have fellow artists,
fellow artists call it,
but wait a minute,
you know,
I'm getting sidetracked here.
I almost forgot to talk about the fucking Lakers.
What the hell was that?
What in God's name was that fucking debacle?
That's how you go out Los Angeles.
Lakers.
You call yourself.
What the fuck was magic talking about where you were classy organization sense
when I think you showed your true colors,
but you're God damn right.
That's how you send out Phil Jackson.
The fucking rent are back of,
of,
of this era.
That's how you send them out by elbow in that little white guy from the
[inaudible].
You see that little spares coming down the fucking pain.
I didn't know he was like maybe an inch taller than I was.
He just looked like some guy,
you know,
who just,
let you know those guys will short guys are the worst.
Whenever you play pickup hoop,
you know they got their fucking balls right on your leg just playing ridiculous
defense.
That was that guy.
So there's part of it that I actually thought was mildly funny,
that he elbowed him.
He went beyond the float and rib.
He cut that rib.
That's right in your fucking armpit.
But uh,
seriously man.
What a,
what a fucking horrific way to go out.
You know what's funny?
This is how much I hate the Goddamn Lakers.
I didn't even watch,
I didn't even watch a minute of basketball for months.
I think the last time I watched the game was when I went to a Memphis Grizzlies
Lakers game.
I don't watch hoop.
I think it's fucking boring as hell.
Pro Hoop,
everybody gets six files.
There's 11 guys on each teams.
That's 132 fucking files.
And then once they get in the penalty,
the fucking game is decided by unguarded shots from the foul line is fucking
horrific.
It's horrific.
But if I see the Lakers are about ready to fail,
that's when I tune in and I got to tell you,
I was out on mother's Day.
Do you guys have a good mother's Day by the way?
Anybody out there did anybody out there order pro flowers?
I haven't heard a fucking word from them so I'm,
I'm taking that as a bad sign.
I don't know that I sold any bouquets.
Oh Maher last week.
I actually had for the first time I had a advertising here on this podcast and I
was all excited.
Right.
And I did sort of my own brand of podcasting [inaudible] advertising where you
sort of dropped,
you know,
hints about serial killers and incest and possibly you say cut in the middle of
the read,
write,
add a.
I don't think,
I don't know that I sold any.
I didn't work too well.
Well you know I,
I try,
I tried to go the fucking every man route.
I try to be loud,
just make this shit conversational.
I'll just say it the way I said,
I thought I painted a nice picture.
I was talking about.
Look what?
What did you get your mother's mother for mother's Day?
Ah,
just the first of all.
Do you deal like your mother?
She's okay.
She's all right.
So yeah,
as you kind of gets on my nerves,
you know,
hey,
it's definitely,
I kind of do it just cause I have to type,
we don't have a really good relationship.
Okay,
so you just got a card.
Yeah.
When did you get it?
Mother's Day.
Sunday.
When did you get a Friday?
You've got a Friday,
right?
The pickings were pretty slim,
aren't they?
Oh,
totally.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
And that's what I was saying.
By the time you get in there,
the only thing that's left is like the Fart joke card or the one that's like
mildly incestuous.
Right,
right,
right.
Totally over the top.
Love your mom.
Yeah,
exactly.
that's what I said.
Yeah.
That's what I still have a ways.
Sony fucking flowers.
I haven't heard one goddamn peep from the people over at pro flowers.
You know what?
Fuck that.
Fuck them and fuck they're fucking flowers.
Right?
You call me with updates.
I'm to one secure,
I can't deal with the silence.
You know,
it's funny.
I bet I sold a bunch of them and now I just told him to go fuck themselves.
It's a novel.
You know what I'm doing?
I'm just going to do this puck.
I want advertising on the same,
but I'm going to continue to do it the way I do it.
And when,
when people finally,
you know,
there'll be products that fit into a saint concert in the middle of it,
right?
Absolutely.
All right.
So anyways,
the fucking Lakers,
the Goddamn Lakers lose.
And uh,
I had just,
it just thrilled me to no end,
but I gotta tell you something.
They went out like a bunch of bitches.
All right.
A bunch of seven foot bitches that I would never say it to their fucking faces,
but I'm saying it right now in the safety of this soundproof room.
What the fuck?
Who,
who,
who the fuck told that guy to take his goddamn shirt off and he wasn't even in
shape.
Andrew buying and maybe you didn't blow out your ankle every time you cross your
fucking legs.
You could do a goddamn set up.
How dare you?
How dare you do something like that with a man who's got 11 championships.
I don't know.
You fucking kills me is,
I'm actually psyched at hopefully that Phil Jackson's going to retire because he
has the ability to,
to,
to coach a team with a bunch of stars.
Much like a Joe Torry and I'm really hoping that motherfucker's going to quit.
You know,
I'm gonna go fucking stare at his naval and do all that Zen shit is he takes
ecstasy or whatever the fuck it is.
He does just get out.
Just get out of the league.
I don't give a fuck if you get back in the league,
go join the heat.
I don't give a fuck.
Just get away from the Lakers.
Right.
But this is what killed me.
I'm hearing rumors that the Lakers are going to get Dwight Howard,
you know,
cause he wants to come out here and be a fucking movie star.
And I was just joking about on Kevin and being like,
what are these basketball players going to realize that they don't have a shot
at being a fucking movie star?
Cause they're too God damn tall.
You know,
don't you see how ridiculous you look in street clothes?
If you ever seen a,
a professional basketball player off the court,
like standing in a bar,
they fucking,
they got to duck every three seconds so they don't get hit by a ceiling fan.
They're freaks.
They're absolute fucking freaks.
You think you're going to sit there and be like a love interest?
Maybe if they remake Conan the barbarian and you want to sit on the back of a
fucking Clyde,
stay on your feet is still dragging on the ground.
We could sticky in that.
It's just pissing me off to Dwight Howard's gonna.
He's gonna come out here and Coby might get another fucking rink.
He,
that guy has no moves,
right?
Do you realize the amount of people who could kick the living shit out of me
that I've already trashed?
When am I trash somebody who can't do anything?
How about a Sama bin Laden everybody.
Huh?
There's one mother fucker won't be knocking on any cave doors anymore.
You don't blow up in my mind is,
I am totally into conspiracy theory,
but the conspiracy theory that people have that he was,
that he was already dead or even better,
that he still fucking alive actually made me laugh.
You know,
paranoid fellow paranoids psychos out there.
Um,
if a Salman bin Laden was still alive,
right,
and you're hanging out with them and America's sitting here gloating heaven,
one of their first truly proud days,
I feel since September 11th,
because that Shit's just been hanging over this country.
Wouldn't you just make a video with the Sama holding the fucking Pakistani
gazette for that day?
Maybe you guys go over to the water park.
He allowed to do that and that part of the world.
Do they add the six flags infiltrated there yet?
The fucking infidels of we,
if we,
if given you a theme park,
you know,
did we come up with some sort of Arab,
uh,
fucking Mickey mouse that we could sell to you?
Maybe stick a fucking Starbucks right next to it.
You know,
wouldn't you just do that and make the video and be like,
I'm still alive.
Go Fuck Yourself,
America.
And then a,
then Obama would look like an asshole and then he would be fucked for 2012 for
saying that,
uh,
that a SAML was dead or if he died years before,
why wouldn't you just released that video?
I don't get it.
You know,
like even even I'm not that fucking paranoid and I think it's a great thing and
all you fucking losers out there who are trying to be all fucking deep going
like,
man,
what's everybody cheering about?
About the killing of a,
of a,
of a fellow human being because he fucking killed 3000 people.
You asshole.
You know,
I,
I love these fucking idiots who are trying to be like all fucking deep as
they're sitting there going like,
oh,
well,
you know,
we got mad at them when they cheered,
when the fucking towers went down and now here we are cheering when a,
it gets killed.
A cycle.
Here's the difference.
All right.
Those,
uh,
sounded been lot actually is a fucking mass murderer who created nine 11.
All right,
so that's who we killed.
We didn't just fucking kill a whole bunch of fucking innocent people and started
sharing.
Isn't that the difference?
Oh,
go fuck yourself.
Okay.
You got a rabid dog in your neighborhood.
You fucking put it down.
Okay.
Do you think,
and I don't like how this guy is being made out by some people sound bit Alon,
like he's some sort of a fucking rebel.
He wasn't,
he was a goddamn psychopath.
And if he was running the world,
would you want,
I don't,
I don't think I'd want to be a chick.
Right.
I wouldn't want to be a,
not only not part of his religion,
but practicing the religion the way he'd feels in a different way than he feels
you should.
The guy was a fucking maniac.
All right?
I thought it was a rebel.
He should be living in a cage,
not sitting in a fucking mansion.
Guy's got a bigger house than I do.
Fuck him.
He was a rich kid.
He was rebelling against his dad.
You've got to beans through the cabbage and they throw them in a lake and I love
it,
you know?
No,
it's funny.
I got,
I got it.
Oh Shit.
Saved by the bell.
I think this might be Jim Norton.
You got to pick up.
He's picking up the phone.
If it's your wife.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Hey guys,
I'm going to be a,
you know what this is.
Sorry.
This is not very professional.
No,
no.
It's all right.
Yeah.
Why the fuck did it,
you know what?
You know how,
what a loser I am.
I didn't even realize at that moment wasn't professional.
Sorry about that.
Jesus Christ.
I was all excited.
You know what Jim was supposed to be on like,
like 15 minutes ago.
I know.
I got a feeling it ain't going to happen.
Busy man like him.
Do you have his number?
Busy man like him?
Uh,
yeah,
I do,
but I'm not going to bug him.
He knows he's supposed to call in,
but I mean,
I dunno if he's wrapping up.
I don't even know what fucking time it is over there.
You know it's going to be fucked.
You know what might be the comedy of this fucking episode is that I came down to
this studio and then nobody calls him.
No,
absolutely.
Nobody calls in Jesus Christ.
What do I do here?
Do I hit pause on the recording and then call my publicist?
Is this what I have to do?
Any port in a storm?
What do you think?
Yeah,
if we could do that right.
Fucking hit pause for half a second.
Sorry everybody.
This is the,
you know what?
This isn't even gonna be a pause in your guys' world.
This is just gonna fucking flow.
All right,
hit pause.
we're back.
Um,
is that,
that thing's not moving over there.
The old EKG monitor.
Are we back?
Oh,
I see.
All right.
Well what back in?
I don't know what the fuck happened.
All I know is David tell he's supposed to be our next guest.
Oh,
fuck me.
Do you guys realize the level of high hopes that I had for this fucking podcast?
I was actually in a real studio.
I actually got a frill professional here to work the Goddamn board,
the levels.
We're going to be great.
I was going to have people calling in last week.
I add advertising media was all good.
What could go wrong?
You know what it's like.
Anybody see that mark,
uh,
that for 30 Marcus dupree story,
I couldn't even get through it.
Skye's like one of the greatest running backs that never made the pros.
He actually finally got to the Rosie,
played a few games with the rams,
have some shit,
but I wanted to feel bad for the guy,
but he was such a dope and he was surrounded by a bunch of dopes that I couldn't
feel bad for him.
I just had to shut it off.
It was just a N***a got another one,
Julie,
uh,
I wasn't in good shape.
A cooler burn book
and it's just like,
all right,
go fuck yourself.
You know,
I'm weird man.
I'm a,
I am like a total fucking like liberal and I and I,
I,
I adjusted my liberal thought,
well,
you know,
I will definitely listen to somebody else's side of the argument,
but if you're not fucking work and to dig yourself out of a fucking hole,
then you know,
bury yourself.
I don't give a shit.
I'm not going to still sit there.
Who's that chick with the big head from all in the family.
She's always standing next to people who need a sandwich.
Right.
I don't give a fuck at that point.
You know,
that didn't even make sense.
You know what it's really trying to say.
It's like,
yeah,
it's like,
I had a buddy of mine just fucking,
his whole,
his whole life became about weed and he just was smoking it all the fucking
time.
He was getting high at work,
getting fucking flunk and drug tests.
Then he starts calling me up,
hey man,
can you give me some money?
And it's like,
no,
go fuck yourself so you can do what?
Go buy a bag and pay your rent.
You can't,
you know,
I,
if you're in a hole in your reaching up out of it going,
help me out,
I'll reach down and pull you out.
But when you're face down,
digging a deeper,
asking me to throw money into it,
go fuck yourself.
Have I said go fuck yourself enough in the last couple of minutes.
Um,
all right.
You know,
I'm just going to plow ahead with this podcast and just do it how I normally do
it.
I'm just going to fucking riff for the rest of the hour and a,
you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to let go of hoping that somebody calls in one of the stars of this
tour that is going to be at the Dar Constitution Hall in Washington DC.
Uh,
stars,
Jim Norton,
Jim Breuer,
David.
Tell on myself and I am beyond fucking excited to play this gig.
Uh,
May 13th this,
this weekend,
Friday 13th.
That's what I'm supposed to be hyping here.
If I could actually just somehow stop my brain from jumping from subject to
subject.
That's,
that's the mission of this fucking podcast is the hype that date.
But,
uh,
that actually that venue,
that's where Eddie Murphy taped delirious.
That's where Chris rock tape one of his specials.
I don't think it was bringing the pain,
but it's still Chris Rock and Martin Lawrence tape there.
So as a standup comedy fan,
slash geek slash,
comedian,
I am beyond excited to be there and I'm hoping that someone's going to call in
from the tour on this show.
I don't know if it's going to happen though.
You know,
it's like it's after the all star break.
We just lost seven games in a row and that last playoff spot is really getting
distant.
I'm starting to let go.
I'm,
I'm fucking letting go of it.
Fuck it.
No one's calling in.
At least it'll sound good,
right?
People.
It'll sound nice,
you know.
Anyways,
you know what I'm talking about earlier and this is what's really fascinating
cause I'm trying to get myself back into shape.
I've dropped like 10 pounds or I'm trying to hold it off fucking actually
salads.
Can you believe that shit?
What?
Are you a fucking queer?
Yes,
I'm eating salads and salad.
Eat and fag add.
Uh,
you got to do it.
This is the thing,
this is what I've learned,
and I might have stated this before,
but this is the fucking thing about being a guy.
Women always bitch about how when they put weight on,
they put it on their ass and their thighs.
Okay.
Which is bad as that must be,
you know,
feeling like you're dragging a tugboat down the fucking street.
You know,
as your kids are sitting there with cereal in their hair,
that's gotta suck.
But at least with the female form,
you know,
gives you guys something to fucking hold on to,
something to slap,
you know,
when he's banging you from behind acting like you're somebody else pushing your
face into the pillow.
You know,
with guys we put our fucking weight on,
it all goes to our goddamn head.
I don't,
I don't know what it is.
And it is crucial as a man in your thirties and forties,
you got to do cardio man or else you're going to get that big fucking Ted
Kennedy head.
And uh,
I was starting to get it.
And there's a few people out there that have just said that are really,
you don't like when they do those,
those,
uh,
for those of you who live in the Midwest or po,
possibly Tampa,
um,
you know,
when they do those before and after photos of what it's like when you're on meth
and you know,
in the one on the left he always looked like some angelic kid who's like student
class president.
And then the next one you look like you're in a fucking Zombie movie.
They had to do that about guys with that,
with like gaining fucking weight and the first billboard that they should use.
And I hate to out somebody,
I hate naming names in the podcast,
but fucking invade Malmsteen is that how you say his Goddamn name?
I am a child of the 80s.
And uh,
this guy was like,
uh,
you know,
the 80s was all about how fucking fast you could play the God damn guitar.
And this guy actually blew past Steve Vai.
That's how fucking fast he played.
And you know,
I don't know what happened to the guy.
His fucking head is to,
there's a monitor.
I wish you guys could see the fucking I.
That's,
I remember the old TV you have when you've got a 27 inch screen TV before flat
screens came out.
You remember that Shit and you thought you were the shit.
You could actually host a Superbowl party cause you got that thing.
That's what his head looks like.
It looks like one of the old style fucking TVs just sitting on there and this is
the thing,
he still teases his hair up to the fucking moon.
He wears leather pants.
He's an absolute fun,
he's a mess.
So there's two things I think you got it.
You got to do as a guy is one,
you got to do the card,
you got to lay off the booze.
I think I'm actually going to come full circle and start advocating weed.
As long as you don't get the Munchies,
get the press,
get that prescription.
If he can do it and you get that we smoked that weed,
that doesn't give you the Munchies,
then you can get buzzed a little bit,
but then you don't chow.
And then,
I don't know,
maybe you can not fucking end up like these guys.
You don't want to be that guy going back to your high school union just bursting
out of your button down shirt,
you know?
Okay.
That big fucking I own a yacht head,
you know,
just bumping into shit,
head getting hit by ceiling fans.
I just don't want to fucking be that guy.
But uh,
we're going to have pictures up on the,
uh,
the M podcast.com.
Is that thing blinking?
No.
Oh,
I thought I started blinking.
I was really praying.
Jesus.
I didn't even prepare for this podcast,
so we know what I realized.
I actually have like people asking me for advice.
Let's,
uh,
let's,
let's read a couple of things.
Everybody gets centering.
This whole thing is just going down the APP Solo.
Shit.
We got somebody.
Oh fuck.
We got a caller.
Hello.
David.
Tell you,
hey,
what's up man?
Hey Gee,
while I'm psyched you actually call Jim Norton.
Never,
uh,
never called it.
I felt like I was hosting like a telethon on,
on basic cable going keep,
keep those,
keep those calls coming in.
And there was like three operators behind me,
just clearly not on the phone.
Okay.
What's that?
Oh,
Jesus.
Bad cell signal.
Yeah.
Um,
is there any way you can,
can you call us back?
Sure.
Can you,
oh wait,
wait.
I can hear you now.
I can hear you now Dave.
Okay.
All right.
Dave,
uh,
you are calling in because we are playing the Dar Constitution Hall.
May 13th is Friday the 13th,
a,
the antisocial tour starring a Jim brewer,
Dave Attell,
Jim Norton and myself.
And uh,
I want to thank you for calling in the show.
You're the only member of the,
uh,
of the tour that actually took time out to call in.
Yeah.
It's going in and out,
but I wanted to say,
I don't know if you hear me,
but I'm calling because I love this show and,
uh,
I think it's going to be a great run at the,
at the,
uh,
in DC.
Yeah,
I got run.
I got,
yeah,
I can hear you.
I hope you can hear me,
dude.
I swear to God,
I met k rock studios.
I'm not doing this for my fucking bedroom.
This is the hot car.
Can't believe this.
This is the whole purpose,
the whole purpose.
Dave of me getting out of my apartment and doing this shit this way so it
actually sound professional.
So when I had one of the fucking best comics out there,
call in,
I could actually hear him.
It's been a cluster.
Fuck Dave.
It's been an absolute cluster fuck.
Um,
anyway,
I called him last night at two 20 in the morning
and they had no idea.
Well,
I was wired.
That was my,
that was my fault.
I should have said a two 20 in the afternoon.
I'll just talk.
It doesn't matter
the
Oh God.
Are we losing them?
Yeah.
Don't call back.
You know what Dave?
Yeah.
Fucking doubt.
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking cluster.
Fuck.
You know,
I could have done this shit.
I could have done this shit from my fucking house.
I could've already had this done.
I occurred.
I could have already uploaded the shit and I could be going to the airport right
now.
Uh,
I don't know if I told you this,
Omar.
I'm actually,
I'm doing another episode of Glee.
This is my second episode.
You're on Gleevec.
Oh yeah,
they have,
it hasn't come out yet.
Okay.
But uh,
I'm doing another one and we actually got to go to New Mexico.
We're doing like this,
this send up a peewee Herman's,
a Mexican hat dance.
So I got to fly out to New Mexico to go do this shit.
And they wanted me to fly out earlier.
Here we go.
Let's see who this is going to be,
Dave again.
Um,
is that him?
Oh,
Jesus.
Yeah.
Can you do me a favor and I can pass this through the war.
Can you believe this?
Can you guys believe the level of unprofessionalism that's fucking going on
right now?
We're not editing out any of this shit.
This is fucking horrific.
Who was that?
That was,
Derek knows Dave.
Dave.
So he's going to be calling back,
calling back.
You know something?
I always thought it was odd that I do these by myself and now I don't.
Now I am totally fucking sold.
He's back on this.
Dave,
what's going on man?
This is great.
Let's see,
node,
fuck all this.
Let's,
let's just get into what everybody knows.
We're going to be at a constitution hall this Friday the 13th,
the anti social network towards Jim Norton,
Jim Breuer,
David Tell on myself,
uh,
for comics for the price of one in the middle of a recession.
I don't know why the fuck you wouldn't buy this ticket,
but,
um,
having said all that,
Dave,
I just,
uh,
just get it off of this fucking subject.
Um,
I,
I saw a bunch of shit this morning where,
uh,
people are coming back around saying that America shouldn't be cheering,
you know,
as Samas death because it's a death of a fellow fucking human being on some
level.
And I'm about as liberal as they come.
And I go like,
wait,
what do you think about that?
Yeah.
Like people are going,
you know,
somebody died.
Doesn't it seem weird to be cheering about the death of somebody?
Well,
I liked
the fact that those kids off of Facebook and out on the streets,
the back flip
and I'm throwing a,
you know,
a beach ball around instead of a human head,
which is how they would've done it in the Middle East.
There you go.
It would have had a nice little,
um,
game of head soccer and um,
no,
I think we,
we,
we earned it.
Um,
we,
uh,
which we call it,
you know,
living in New York City,
it's nice to see cheering that doesn't involve some kind of parade.
Um,
you know,
like whether it be of the Latino variety or the other Puerto Rican day parade,
which is always,
exactly,
yeah.
So for women,
for everyone.
But the fun thing about it,
Bill,
it's that like,
as we're getting more information about him,
he's becoming less like,
um,
like evil.
It just more normal and sad.
Like the rest of us,
like he lived in two rooms with three women and a,
he spent most of his time on the computer.
You know,
it's just like looking at TV,
dying his beard.
I got to,
I was a little jealous that he had probably a bigger apartment than I think I
was living in a fucking mansion.
I gotta tell you Dave,
I gotta I got it.
I do have to give the guy props as far as how long it took us to find us because
I've got to ask you this.
If,
if an entire nation was looking for you,
like how long do you think it would take him to get?
Yeah,
yeah,
10 minutes.
This guy,
uh,
for his,
his little infrastructure jumping from cave to cave,
I made,
I,
you know,
10 years.
That's,
that's almost as amazing as how long magic has lived with HIV.
There was a good comparison there,
but I think Pakistan did let us down,
but they are our best friend and you know,
much like any friends who would give him a lot of money and they tell you what
you want to hear and I'm in while they're fucking you over.
So I really can't see why everyone's so surprised about it.
But,
um,
I think we should slam them a bit.
Here's my idea.
You Ready?
Yep.
They have to come in last at the parade of the Olympics.
Okay.
For all the other countries,
Peru,
Paraguay,
Pakistan,
no,
I'm sorry.
No,
you're gonna have to wait
the wraps around Zimbabwe.
Yeah.
It's no more alphabetical.
It's by order of country who is helping us on the warring terror and uh,
they can come in and Germany will be like,
we went through this,
you know,
they'll get over it.
Um,
eventually,
you know,
there'll be known for you're a World Trans Music and uh,
by curious,
um,
uh,
porn.
But uh,
yeah,
that's
so just how it is.
So,
uh,
yeah,
I'm a little,
I'm a little upset with Pakistan,
but I think it was a great win.
And uh,
I like how they had to describe to people what the Navy seals or I guess any,
any um,
uh,
who are they describing that too?
Cause every guy in their life wanting to be a navy seal at one point.
Like I'm going to be a navy seal.
Oh wait,
that involves a lot of swimming outside of a pool.
Yeah.
You've got to have abs right there.
I was out.
I'm for some reason thought that when I was a kid I didn't realize that they did
shit on land.
I thought they were like the real live Aquaman.
Like if there was,
if there was a bad ship,
they come over the side with a knife in their mouth.
Well it's land,
sea and air bill.
So if he had like let's say put on like a jet pack,
they would have followed him into the cloud.
I like to have fucking,
people are trying to like,
oh are we going to see the identity of the people that whack down on me?
Just like why?
Why would you think that you,
you know,
did we ever see the identity of those other two guys in the shrubs who shot
Kennedy?
They always give you the one guy.
They'll give you a lot though.
I
will eventually meet these guys because I play a lot of the funny bones and
Improv towns near where they live and any do who was in the military will be
coming out to me.
Like,
you know,
I was the dude who shot him,
man.
Yeah.
Was,
that was me trying to keep it on the down low.
Can I have,
can I have a free DVD there,
Mr Hotel,
speaking of which,
ah,
do you have anything,
um,
anything you want to hype as far as I know,
wait a minute.
You know what I uh,
David Tell actually,
is it okay to announce a,
your upcoming TV show?
No,
but I'm,
yeah,
I'm working on a project.
And Bill,
you were very cool and you've got to take a look a little bit about it involves
a safe,
it's a,
it's a little dirtier,
but,
um,
I think it's going to be fun and that's come out sometime this summer.
I did a show with bell where we look,
watch porn.
So,
um,
you know,
we have,
believe it or not,
it's,
it's not only is it hilarious,
but the way they did it,
because I was worried some of the stuff that we were watching,
I was,
I was wondering how you guys were gonna pull that off and get that on air and
I'm not going to give away what they did,
but I watched it and I,
uh,
on the last date we did up in Foxwoods and I thought it was,
it was hilarious,
was actually genius with what you guys were doing because some of that stuff was
pretty hardcore.
And,
uh,
it was actually hilarious to watch.
And,
uh,
I dunno.
I,
I think,
I dunno,
I don't want to jinx it,
but I think he got a good shot with that one.
Knock on wood.
Well,
thank you for doing it too,
man.
You were,
you were very cool.
And,
uh,
you know,
it's very hard.
I know you got like a,
you do a lot of road are you're doing this tour with me and knowing then a
brewer and uh,
also you've got this podcast and going in,
I think it's Kinda cool that you're in the studio,
you know,
and uh,
a,
is this kind of like a dream?
I guess you'd kind of like bumped up to like regular,
you know,
like this is like the real deal man.
I mean like are you dressed like a radio guy?
Oh,
absolutely.
I have a,
I have a rock tee shirt on from the 70s.
I'm going to have the wacky guy will make sound effects and that type of shit.
Breakfast Burrito,
no matter what time it is.
Oh,
Dave,
I've got to put you on hold.
We've got the weather guy coming up next.
I'm not joking.
I'm joking.
Totally joking.
Um,
he was so good at it.
I was like,
oh,
I'm so used to that.
Like,
sure.
Whatever.
That's cause I went into my,
uh,
my radio guy voice.
That's,
that's nice.
He,
you have a good radio name.
How about like I said,
uh,
you know,
how about like double fee,
a Bang Bang or something like that?
Yeah.
It has to either be an abbreviation or there has to be some,
this might,
my sidekick has to have like an,
an animal name,
you know?
Yeah.
You listen to double B and the Gazelle,
he alive on 97.1.
We got this next guy coming in and then I'll ask you the worst fucking questions
that you've heard a zillion times.
Dave,
do you get nervous before you go out on stage?
Yeah.
You know what I love?
I like when people,
uh,
radio guys always ask me about like going on stage when like,
I've had radio guys open for me and they looked like terrified.
Like they've never seen the audience that they talked to me every morning.
Yeah.
That's what they look like.
That's them.
You think you were that?
Yeah,
they're always drinking.
They're always drinking before they go out on stage to just trying to calm the
nerves.
It's hilarious.
Good.
I like,
you know,
I gotta get Outta here,
man.
I got wet t shirts concert across town and then,
you know,
I'm up here in park dealership tomorrow.
So,
uh,
now they always have like a busier life to me.
I'm jealous.
That's what it is.
Well,
well
I think it's going to be a good show.
And so those were the people who did come to Fox.
And uh,
of course,
uh,
when we were in Atlantic city,
this was our first show outside of the casino world.
Now I am against it,
but the rest of the guys,
I'm just or think that we have the juice to make to make it happen.
So I'm going with these guys,
but I saw this,
I was like a casino act exclusively like a Sonny and Cher.
You remember like a,
like a,
like the Osmonds,
you know,
like we've toured exclusively from casino to casino.
Absolutely.
You know,
and like conventions and stuff like that.
And then,
you know,
cause uh,
you guys still have like a chance,
but I'm coughing old hack riding an old credit.
So I'll be here.
Like this is perfect for me.
You know,
like eventually I'll like work at the casino,
you know,
it will be a greeter at the door.
So,
you know,
you're saying it was all like the last round up before you hit the cruise ships.
You know,
I always felt casinos when,
when you,
when you signed that that you know,
I will stay here all year round out in Vegas.
That's,
yeah,
that was basically a landlocked cruise.
Ship Gig was basically a year you had a fear of the ocean,
but you've definitely tapped.
But you've definitely tapped out from the business.
But I have to admit though,
every once in awhile,
like when I'm sick of doing the road,
you start thinking,
you start lying to yourself basically.
That,
you know what?
I think I could do that.
You know,
I'll just get myself a nice house and I'll just do the,
uh,
I'll just do the flamingo every fucking weekend.
But,
uh,
I don't,
I don't think I could tackle what's that?
I'm older than you.
So my dream is like,
yeah.
You know,
like once I hit 50,
I go to Vegas,
I like buy a house with enough room in the back so it can be like a shooting
range,
ATV tours,
stripper wife,
you know,
we'll like,
we'll run that during the day.
At night I'll do my,
my shitty ass show and then,
you know,
um,
we'll just slowly die of a sun cancer and that's what it is.
What do you know?
Uh,
I've talked to a lot of people,
like the security people out there in Vegas as far as like some of the bigger
entertainers.
I'm always fascinated with that stuff and uh,
I think that they are fully aware of how bad shit crazy you go having as a
performer having to work not only a casino but the same fucking casino,
you know,
five,
six nights out of the week.
And uh,
I'm fascinated with how little time all the performers,
like spend out there.
Like someone's trying to tell me like all of them I heard like,
like George Carlin when he would do like the two weeks they would have like a
limo waiting,
right?
Like they would pull up like five minutes or 10 minutes before the show.
He would get out,
he'd do his hours,
say thanks a lot.
Good night before the crowd even put like their jackets on to go back out to the
casino floor.
He's already in the car heading back to wherever the hell he is staying.
And the,
the best one I heard was Celine Dion evidently gets helicoptered from her
fucking house to the top to the top of the casino.
Does,
is show punches herself in the chest a couple of to get the notes out and then
she goes right back up and flies back to her fucking house.
Yeah,
no,
she has the navy seals.
They totally,
they fly in and they extract or
well,
maybe they'll shoot her in the leg.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well,
that girl's available now.
So where are the housewives of,
uh,
of a,
a Bob about city.
I want to see that show.
You got a lot of hard,
you know what?
I've actually heard that they have even worse plastic surgery than the American
ones.
That's why they way that little veil.
Oh,
really?
That's,
um,
that's,
that's the rumor on the Internet.
All right,
well,
before we,
before I get outta here,
Dave,
uh,
for just,
I really appreciate your coming here and eating up seven minutes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I know you're a,
you're a busy guy and everything and I gotta tell you guys I can't.
Oh,
I like,
usually when you hype something,
you're overhyping it.
You're saying it's better than it is,
but I got to tell you,
uh,
I,
I've done,
I've done four shows with these guys and every show,
I'm standing to the side of the stage watching everybody.
This is,
this is your out of your fucking mind if you don't come out to this thing.
Okay.
I'm not talking about myself.
These other three guys were on this tour are absolutely killing it every night.
And,
uh,
we're going to be at the Dar Constitution Hall this Friday.
Um,
May 13th please come down.
Uh,
tickets,
tickets are going fast.
And,
uh,
how bout it for the wonderful David Tell for calling in the show.
Thank you very much manual.
My first calling.
Oh,
thanks bill.
All right,
I'll see you there.
All right brother.
See you Friday.
All right.
Bye Bye.
See Ya.
All right,
there we go.
Now if this was a professional show and had some sort of advertise and be like,
oh well good,
I'll be black and five minutes and I go down the hall,
right.
Drink a coffee,
take a shit or whatever it is.
He morning people do how far into this thing I was.
Shit,
we're coming up on an hour.
Yep.
Ah Jeez.
All right.
You know what,
what,
what?
You know what?
I'm just going to get into the normal bullshit that I do for this week and we
got,
I'm going to read some stuff.
Oh,
mark,
do you remember back when you were in elementary school?
Yeah.
And they made you read out loud and there was always that kid who was so fucking
horrific.
You thought he was like borderline retarded.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's who I am.
So if you thought we were going to get out of here on time,
it ain't happening.
So fucking,
uh,
put your feet up on the console there.
Cause I'm about ready to start reading out loud.
All right,
here we go.
This is going to be the,
uh,
the advice for a,
for this week for some stupid reason.
You guys keep asking me for advice.
A high bill,
just to give you some background,
I'm a 36 year old Asian woman that was born and raised in the bay area.
Um,
I've been married for six years and I have a beautiful baby girl.
They always start off nice,
everything's great and there's a nice summer breeze blowing up my skirt.
Um,
the only reason I am telling you this is because I wanted you to know that there
are wives,
mothers and Asians that listen to your podcasts.
That thank you are funny.
Uh,
do I think you're an asshole?
Yes.
But you're a funny ass hole and that's all that matters.
This just check is cool as hell.
Don't ever let a few idiots that can't take a joke.
Joe,
get you down.
All right,
so a few podcasts ago,
uh,
you that not,
not every,
not very many women were writing in.
I decided that I should start Jesus Christ.
This is,
this is exactly how they tell a fucking story.
Three minutes before we were,
when did we get to the meat of this shit?
Cobbly weeks ago you sounded down and I was watching Oprah and I realized I
haven't called my friend from high school.
So anyways,
I decided to start pulling my weight and shoot you an email for advice.
I knew,
I know that you grew up in a family of all boys.
Um,
can you please tell me what is the best way to deal with the troubled male
teenager?
One of my friends is a single mom and is worried about her 14 year old son.
Oh Jesus.
This is going to be rough.
Um,
he used to be a pretty happy kid,
but lately he's become very quiet and keeps to himself.
Most of the time.
My friend doesn't know if anything is really wrong,
but when she asks for a,
for his response,
his response is always,
everything's fine.
Everything's fine.
All right.
Close the door.
Thank you.
Um,
he's not rude and he's not getting into any trouble that she knows if she just
concerned because he comes home from school and goes straight to his room.
She wants to know if everything is okay but is unsure of how to approach the
situation.
As you know,
men don't always love opening up,
let alone a teenage boy.
Do you have any suggestions?
Yes,
I do.
As a matter of fact,
um,
first thing I would be worried about is,
uh,
I dunno,
it was easy lovesick it or is he a,
is he being bullied at school?
Maybe that's what it is.
Did something fucking horrific,
something unbelievably humiliating the happen to him.
And now there's a fucking youtube video out there of it with 1.2 fucking million
hits.
That's one of the worst things about something awful happening to you now as a
kid is these fucking asshole other kids.
They all have cameras,
they film it and you fuck your fucking life is over.
So I don't know what it is.
I mean,
I hope it's not drugs or anything like that,
but if I was in that situation and the kid was an opening up,
uh,
I try to spend more time with them,
um,
in order to compare this to,
I was never able to pick up a girl and like a meat market,
like in a bar.
I was never able to do that shit because they had the defenses up there fucking
ready for you to come at him that way.
And I think when they're sitting in their fucking room that just in that mode
you become in Sohn,
is everything okay?
You know,
plus they got to hide their weed or whatever's going on there.
But,
uh,
I think if,
if you just get them outside of that shit,
um,
I,
you know what,
I don't know.
I'm not a fucking parent,
but I think at some point I would just address say,
listen,
I'm not trying to Pry,
I'm not trying to be an asshole here,
but I've just noticed that you seem a little quieter than usual.
Um,
did you knock somebody up?
You know,
eventually come around to that question.
You know what,
that question I think,
I think it's beyond me.
I guess that that's what I would do.
I would try to,
uh,
I don't know.
I don't know what the kids into fees until if he's,
yeah,
what are you from the bay area?
He likes the A's or the fucking giants buy tickets and then lie and say,
Oh,
I won these tickets at work.
So then he won't feel like a Douche gone with his mom.
Take to the game with the mom.
You shoot the shit,
you have a good time.
And eventually,
I don't know,
you get a couple of beers in him now he's 14.
I don't fucking know the,
I,
I think I would just address the fact that he seems quieter than usual.
Um,
I would see if he's hanging out with anybody new or different,
and if they,
if they look like John Bender from the fucking breakfast club,
I'd be worried that maybe he was dabbling in drugs.
Um,
I don't know.
But that's a weird age.
I know.
That's right.
When I started feeling like a fucking freak,
like my elementary school days were good and right around junior high,
that's a,
that that went good.
High School,
high school.
Where's,
where kind of went off the rails for me.
So he's right about 14,
I don't know,
maybe he's a freshman and he feels like you know,
all these fucking,
you know,
seniors are free.
Get I'm out.
I Dunno.
It just feels like he's got to start all over again.
I have no fucking idea that's beyond me and I'm going to give you bad advice and
then I'm going to get sued.
So sorry.
But thank you for writing in.
I do appreciate it.
Um,
all right,
Jesus.
This,
this might be the worst fucking podcast I've ever done.
You know,
with my luck,
the people at k rock are actually listening to this and they were actually
considering giving me a fucking job and now it's over.
Right.
Well,
all right,
Bill.
Hey,
one of my best friends has been going to church for years old,
g,
g h and previously it has never bothered me at all.
I grew up Catholic and like so many Catholics,
I no longer attend church.
Gee,
why was that?
Was it the kid fucking or the,
uh,
money they took from the Nazis in World War Two?
Um,
anyways,
but it doesn't bother me in the least if someone wants to go.
That's how I feel.
Honestly,
a few months ago,
my friends started asking me if I would like to go to church with them.
Oh God,
I politely declined.
That just gave me chills.
That is fucking arms accidentally graze up against your hand when he said it.
Anyways,
since then,
my friend has told me he feels it's his mission to spread the word of God and
continues to ask me to go.
And as time passes,
he's getting more aggressive with his church sales pitch.
What started off with him just slipping it into casual conversation has now
laugh.
How the fuck do you do that?
You want to go to subway?
Yeah.
Get me the Italian on Italian bread and uh,
you know,
Jesus,
uh,
evidently he used to be around Italy,
wasn't he in Italy when he got crucified?
Um,
so anyways,
he casually been slipping this into the conversation now as led to me receiving
text messages that say the following,
this,
this means more to me than,
you know,
God has poured out love to me and he is reaching out to you.
Oh,
so ignore a few must,
but there is a lot at stake here to this.
I applied.
Honestly,
if it's my choice,
I don't want to go,
please stop asking me about it.
I don't know how many more ways I can request that his was,
he responded with,
I'll hold off,
but know this God,
you and will not quit if I do.
Oh my God.
This sounds like the first draft of single white female.
Um,
here comes my question.
Bill,
what does this,
why does this fucking Piss me off so much?
Because it's creepy.
Ah,
why do these,
why do these cults,
uh,
what do these cults do to these people?
He is involved with the Church that people do joke around about and do call a
cult a,
what would you do if you or me at this point,
I don't even want to talk to this guy because these conversations are
infuriating me.
Um,
there's nothing you can do.
You've got to look out for yourself.
You've got to cut this guy out of your life.
That's it.
It's fucking over.
He joined a Goddamn cult.
There's nothing you can do about it.
If you try to get them to,
to see the light and not come out and come out of the cult,
you're immediately going to be a whatever,
whatever creepy word they use in his cult for the outsiders.
You know,
you're,
you're one of the others and you're,
and you're just going to drive them further into the fucking cult.
All right?
Hopefully he's good with weaponry and uh,
you know,
for when the FBI surrounds the compound and ask them to come out nicely.
Um,
let me guess.
Is the guy at the top,
does he have loans,
you know,
that they're following?
Who started this cult?
Does he have long hair?
And a beard.
You know,
if it's a white guy,
I think that that's how it usually goes.
Is He wearing high top gym sneakers?
Are they waiting for some sort of flying fucking saucer though?
Do you know what I would do if I was you?
I would,
and this might actually help them to come around.
Just cut him out of your life.
Just stop answering his text messages.
Don't hang out with them anymore.
And uh,
when he asked why,
I say,
dude,
cause you're out of your fucking mind.
That's why you're out of your fucking mind.
There's like 9,000 religions on this planet and they all say go somewhere
different.
Why do you think you don't even say,
why do you think you're right?
You're out of your fucking mind.
Alright.
You Die.
You go in the ground,
you become a fossil fuel with the stegosaurus.
That's it.
All right.
And someday if you have any gift and put any fucking luck,
you'll get extracted out of the ground and to be going right through a fucking
carburetor.
You know,
helping some asshole get to work.
Maybe go over to his girl house.
You know,
so we can,
you can get his first piece of pussy.
Other than that,
it's all fucking horse shit.
All you need is a 10 commandments.
If you follow those,
if there is some sort of after party,
some sort of VIP room at the end of your life,
you're going to fucking get in.
All right.
Fuck these people.
Cut them out of your life.
All right,
I think I've got time for one more and then I've got to get the fuck outta here.
Cause like I said,
I got a flat in New Mexico and I'm doing another episode of Glee and I know you
guys think I'm fucking around,
but I'm telling you,
this is episode number two and I got a damn.
But Bap,
bap,
bap.
All right,
number three,
bill first can't thank you enough for all the laughs and your weekly podcasts.
I just realized I don't have enough time to read this because it was something I
wanted to talk about.
I'm going to close it on this one.
Here's a youtube video you guys have to watch this week.
All you gotta do is search Chuck Berry,
John Lennon,
Memphis,
or you can just go to the [inaudible] podcast.com and you see this video.
And,
um,
I don't know how to describe this.
Basically what goes on here,
speaking of women,
um,
as much as people talk about the Beatles and how great their music is,
was whatever you want to say,
I totally agree with them.
I think that the greatest band of all time,
but I have to be honest with you,
John Lennon and Paul Mccartney redefined pussy whipped.
Okay.
They,
they,
you remember what,
like when Jordan came into the NBA and he just took it 20 years into the fucking
future,
this is what these guys did with being pussy.
What people thought they knew what pussy with was.
You have to watch this fucking video.
It's John Lennon is singing with Chuck Berry.
Chuck Berry is probably one of the main reasons why John Lennon,
Lennon ever picked up a guitar.
So now he's on TV.
He gets to play with this idle,
they're playing,
uh,
Chuck Berry's hit Memphis.
Okay.
John Lennon's got Yoko in his fucking band.
They're in the middle of singing this song on television and they're killing it.
It's going great.
And I didn't Yoko's playing some stupid fucking drum.
And even though she has no fucking talent whatsoever,
he's putting her in the fucking band.
Just she'll,
she'll shut the fuck up and stop nagging him cause he's too much of a fucking
pussy to tell her that she has no talent.
All right.
The only reason why you're here Yoko's cause you're sucking my dick.
No,
you can't play the bongos.
But anyway,
she's up there playing the Bongos,
right?
So John Lennon,
Chuck Berry,
two of the greats of all time harmonizing singing this hit from the 1950s that's
what this moment's about.
And Yoko in the middle of it,
can't handle that.
She's not getting any shine.
She takes the fucking microphone out of the stands,
starts playing the Bongo,
and as they're singing,
you know,
go,
go Johnny,
go whatever.
She picks up the mic and I swear to God goes,
okay,
some fucking crazy shit.
And you see Chuck Berry's eyes fucking open as wide as they are.
And it's that.
It's that fucking look,
dude,
you ever have like a buddy of yours?
And he's,
he's,
he's dating some fucking psycho,
but he's in love with her so you can't fucking say anything and you're just
sitting there waiting for the fucking lightning bolt to hit your friend in the
head where he finally realizes that he's dating a psycho cunt.
Chuck Berry had that look on his face.
Dude,
I'm not even joking.
Like I'm not even exaggerating.
She,
hey,
that's what the fuck she did.
And Chuck Berry's like,
what the fuck?
And it's kind of like John,
that's your woman get her in line.
And John Lennon does not even fucking,
he doesn't even blink.
He just,
he just keeps playing and then she does it again later on in that song.
And then you look at all the other musicians and they just keep playing the
song.
Like Yoko isn't even fucking there.
And I,
I dunno,
I,
I can't,
I thought I was going to be able to describe it to a level feed up to you to
understand it,
but you got to watch this video,
John Lennon and what's his face,
Courtney putting that monotone.
Not only does he have are playing keyboards,
he's got to sing in background.
I mean the two of them,
I don't think they just did not have their women in line.
And uh,
I actually get infuriated when I watched this video.
The fact that John didn't just stop playing in that moment and what he should've
done was dressed or down right there.
Yes.
I find you want to have a fucking moment.
This is your mom.
If you ever fucking do that again,
I will slap you so fucking hard in the head.
Your eyes are going to look like mine.
Do you understand me?
You play that fucking Bongo and you shut your face.
You look like that bitch.
You crawled out of the fucking well and ring.
You understand me?
I didn't mean to.
Why I'm fucking you.
I got to be fucking anybody.
You can't play the punk bongos.
You can't sing.
Shut your fucking face.
And then he just walks back up to the mic and just counts the band back in.
Right.
Is that what the fuck he should've done.
All right.
Whatever this thing has been a cluster fuck.
I want to thank you.
I want to thank David.
Tell for actually calling in.
I got one one out of the other three guys to call and Bruce said he couldn't
call in.
Jim Norton is just phenomenally busy.
Plus the guy also put together this tour so I can't get upset at him.
And uh,
I'm fucking here.
You got half the Goddamn tour,
right?
You got two out of four.
Just like the Beatles,
Paul Mccartney and the,
who else has left?
Ringo Starr.
Wait a minute.
The other two are dead.
No,
not on this tour.
They're both alive.
And then we're going to be at constitution hall.
Friday the 13th I'll might as well hot the other dates.
This tour is coming through a Chicago.
We're going to beat the Chicago theater on June 15th the paramount theater in
Seattle on July 1st and then we're going to be at a Vegas,
I forget the name of the casino on July 3rd all hype it next week and next week
I believe will be my 200 podcast.
So I'll be eating cake next week.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
I hope it made sense.
I know it was a little bit of a cluster fuck.
Uh,
but that said,
go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].